2014 när vi startade med Foodbox så var det nog ännu färre som köpte frysmat.
Idag tycker jag att det finns mycket frysmat att köpa.
Sen vet jag att det mesta är inte riktigt av den kvalitén jag skulle vilja köpa.
Det är skit helt enkelt.
Jag ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löst det, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Alton Bladet sen.
Jag ska hitta på ett namn på podden.
Är det den bästa idé vi har?
Inte den sämsta idé vi har.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Exakt, det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt, det kör vi på.
Det får det bli, klart.
Då går vi vidare.
Då var det dags för ännu ett avsnitt med podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Idag har vi Frank Angelini från Foodbox här.
Tack så mycket.
Det är verkligen roligt att få vara med här idag.
Jag ser fram emot att få dela lite erfarenheter och prata om viktiga ämnen.
Tanken är att vi ska diskutera Foodbox som är en av dina bebisar.
Men jag är lite nervös för att vi ska sväva iväg och hamna i många andra ämnen.
Jag ska försöka hålla mig på banan här och leda kursen.
Kan vi inte börja lite grann med en kort intro för folk?
Vem Frank är?
Jo gärna.
Frank Angelini som sagt var pluggare till Chiropractor på sent 80-tal, klar 93.
Har drivit ett 20-tal gym genom årens lopp.
Har arbetat och utvecklat med olika vitt minstningsprogram.
Det senaste var Whitetrainer som vi sålde för ett par år sedan.
Tillvälkat och sålt träningsutrustning, kraftmark och drivit och arbetat med affärssystemet Wander.
Som vi också sålde här för lite drygt ett år sedan.
Och en del andra saker också.
Om jag får auta så har jag något spännande på gång till hösten också.
Det är ju ett koncept för hälsolösningar som heter Set a Go.
Som egentligen är till för att hjälpa människor att sätta hälsomål.
Och som också gör att en träningsanläggning nu verkligen kan revolutionera sitt utbud och erbjuda helt ny och spännande aktivitet till sina kunder.
Det var inte det vi skulle fastna i men kan du säga lite mer vad det projektet handlar om?
Eller det företaget?
Under många år, egentligen de senaste 20 åren, så har jag pratat mycket om paketering av framförallt personlig träning.
Tycker det är viktigt att människor ska förstå vad det är de köper och handlar.
Och pratat mycket hälsa med.
Och sen under årenslopp så har det varit mycket snack, ibland från större kedjer i branschen om att hälsa är viktigt.
Vi måste öppna upp och fokusera mer på hälsa.
Det kan inte bara vara träning.
Men det har inte hänt så mycket.
Och sen nu här under pandemin så var det ju ännu mer snack om hälsa.
Att det är viktigt att ha en bra grundhälsa för att ha stark motståndskraft och bra immunförsvar.
Och ingenting hände då heller.
Och då tänkte jag bara, nu tar vi tag i det här.
Så nu har vi tagit fram ett koncept där vi egentligen har hälsolösningar.
För dig som sover dåligt, för dig som behöver stressa mindre, för den som har ont, för den som behöver komma i bättre form och så vidare.
Så det är ett heltäckande koncept egentligen.
Som mellanfering nu till hösten.
Så jag hoppas att de därute kommer att hålla ögonen öppna på det.
Okej, kul.
Sätt det golet heter det.
Ja.
Men du har hängt i branschen ett tag, låter det som?
Ja, 36 år.
Sedan var det jag startade.
Så jag har levt hela mitt yrkesverksamma liv egentligen i den här branschen.
Jag har försökt sticka ut lite grann i klädbranschen och så vidare, men det är inte långvarigt utan tillbaka i den här branschen igen.
Det har varit där jag känner att jag mår som bäst.
Att arbeta med människor som vill göra förändringar och må bättre.
Det är viktigt tycker jag.
Jag tänker att du har haft ett antal företag där.
Vilket var det roligaste, vilket tyckte du var jobbigast att sälja?
Oj, egentligen alla.
Man blir ju lite grann förälskad i sin egen skapelse.
Jag har inte varit helt själv och skapat allting.
Jag tycker att det är lite svårt att skiljas från alla.
Men det är var tid som har sin sak.
Jag och min kollega som jag har haft, eller kompanjon, sedan 36 år också, vi började faktiskt plugga i Chirupractor tillsammans.
Jag och Pell Sundström har byggt och drivit de flesta företag tillsammans.
Det har känts bra allting egentligen.
Hela resan har fungerat bra.
Vad är det som har gjort att när ni har känt att ett företag ska gå vidare, hur vet ni det?
Det är väl en känsla egentligen som man får.
Att man är lite klar med någonting.
Både jag och min kollega är ju startresidenten.
Vi gillar att bygga, skapa, utveckla, se saker och ting, att vi får ett fäste och att det blir ett intresse runt om att det faktiskt fungerar.
Sen har vi jobbat ganska lång tid.
Ta till exempel Foodbox som vi ska prata mer om här nu, det startade 2014 så det är inte så att vi bara startar och säljer, utan vi hänger ju i ganska länge med vissa etableringar också.
Vi gillar att jobba och skaffa.
Jag förstår, jag förstår.
Hur har ni, eftersom ni har drivit bolag så länge ihop eller olika bolag, hur brukar ni styra upp det ganska bäddat för konflikter ibland när man driver bolag med folk?
Ja, jag brukar fundera på det och har förstått att det är ganska unikt att hänga ihop med någon så länge och faktiskt göra det utan att ha några konflikter eller någonting sånt.
Men det kanske har varit två tjafs på 36 år, mer än så är det inte.
Vi har hittat varandras styrkor tror jag.
Vi respekterar varandra, vi gillar att göra samma saker, vi älskar att jobba båda två, så vi får nästan hålla om för varandra, ta det nu lite lugnt, vila, stressa inte.
Jag tror att det gäller att hitta och respektera varandra, hitta en partner man gillar och respektera och jobba fram.
Det har väl varit själva nyckeln i det hela.
Vi ska ju framförallt fokusera på Foodbox, tänker jag, för det är lite spännande koncept och relativt, alltså det borde ju inte vara så unikt, men affärsmodellen som ni kör är ju ändå relativt ensam i Sverige på den nivån kan man väl säga.
Men för de som inte vet vad Foodbox är, skulle du kunna ge en liten hisspitch?
Ja, Foodbox består av egentligen 13 färdiglagade maträtter, nyttiga, utan tillsatser, snabb infrysta för att behålla alla näringsämnen på ett bra sätt.
Och det ska vara enkelt, bekvämt för en kund att kunna plocka med sig en Foodbox från frysen på gymmet.
Och på det här så har vi också byggt ett affärssystem runt omkring Foodbox.
Där vi faktiskt hjälper våra återförsäljare att såklart sälja mycket, men också få nya medlemmar med hjälp av Foodbox.
Så vi har olika kampanjer och produkter och sånt kring det.
Men Foodbox är egentligen nyttig färdiglagad mat som säljs via gymmanläggningar, är det så jag?
Ja, och själva grunden till det är ju under perioden vi själva drev träningsanläggningar, vi har haft jätteanläggningar med restauranger och vi har haft mindre restauranger med små kaféer.
Men den ledande, alltså den springande punkten, vi alla gym vi har drivit är ju att ofta får du slänga massa mat, färdiga sallader, smörgåsar, ja men det går ut i datum och blir inte så trevligt och bra, så mycket, mycket svin.
Och då tänkte jag och Pelle här för många, många år sedan att alltså, går inte det här att lösa på något sätt?
Det här är ju en stor egentligen problem i branschen att man får slänga så mycket, plus att det är ganska chaskig mat på gymmen med.
Och ja men vi satte oss ner och funderade ganska länge innan vi kom fram till, ja men fryst mat kan det vara någonting.
Om vi ser till att den frysta maten är supergod, god, smakrik och att den är nyttig och inte innehåller några konserveringsmedel alls, kan man ta till det.
Det var så det började.
Efter mycket om och med en så stod vi där med möjligheten att faktiskt tillverka vår första batch.
Men det var ganska mycket pengar att handla om för att få igång produktionen överhuvudtaget.
Men vi hoppar in i det.
Och på den vägen är det.
Men det säljs bara via gymmen?
Framförallt, vi har varit där.
Vi har under årens lopp sagt nej till säkert hundra livsmedelsbutiker som vill ha Foodbox.
Vi har inte arbetat så mycket på företag heller, men där har det slunkit igenom.
Vi har ett sjuttiotal företag också som köper Foodbox.
Men vi känner ju att vår core business, vi har varit i träningsfären i branschen, som jag sa i 36 år, det är där vi vill vara.
Så det är framförallt hälsoträningsanläggningar som är återförsäljande till Foodbox.
Nu ska jag inte tjata om detta, men jag driver också företag och jag blir bara är det inte en stor revenue stream som försvinner om man skulle kunna få det mer mainstream?
Jo, säkert.
Vi har ju tänkt på det många gånger.
Ska vi inte in på dvh, alltså livsmedelsbranschen, eller ska vi inte trycka på mer på företagen och så vidare.
Men vi känner mer att det är hellre kvalitet än kvantitet.
Vi älskar att jobba med branschen.
Vi drivs också av att kunna hjälpa våra kolleger i branschen som driver anläggningar att bli lönsamma.
Det har varit vårt mål med.
Egentligen alla koncept och företag vi har haft inom träningsbranschen så har det mest handlat om att försöka hjälpa andra träningsanläggningar att bli lönsamma och tjäna pengar.
Så det är därför vi har fastnat där.
Dels är det lite intressant hur många gymnasier finns på idag och dels kan du förklara lite det här konceptet runtomkring foodboxen så det blir väl en tudelad fråga.
Det finns på 650 orter eller 650 gym runt om i landet och ett 70-tal företag också som jag sa.
Vi har också typ fyra livsmedelsbutiker som har chatat i dot och så vidare.
Så det är egentligen från långt ner i söder upp till norr i Norrland som vi finns etablerade på träningsanläggningar.
Och vi har ju själva drivit en hel del tränningsanläggningar och vet att en utmaning kan ibland vara att få in nya medlemmar.
Man jagade ständigt efter bra kampanjer, bra möjligheter att kunna rekrytera nya medlemmar.
Och jag har alltid varit av det viset att man inte ska rabattera bort sig själv heller.
Det är ju annars vanligt att man bara ger bort massa träning för att få in ny kund och så vidare.
Men då har vi utvecklat en del kampanjer.
Bland annat en som heter Foodbox Challenge.
Som innebär att man söker efter deltagare som vill vara med under en månad, äta bra mat och träna tillsammans för att komma i lite bättre form.
Och det finns ett liknande program som vi kallar för Foodbox Race, där man faktiskt kan köra i enskilt.
Vi har Foodbox Go, som är en kortare kickstartvariant på tio dagar med Foodbox.
Vi håller också på att utveckla Foodbox 21 Camp, som ska bli som en liten bootcamp.
Det här kommer vi att lansera till hösten också.
Vi tycker att det är viktigt att ha den hjälpen runt omkring för att skapa lite grann lite bass, få människor mer intresserade av Foodbox och faktiskt förstå och känna att det kan vara en produkt som hjälper dem mycket för att bli hälsosammare och må bra.
Jag fattar, men så ni styr upp någon sorts koncept som kunderna ska följa och sedan gymmens, vad ska man säga, vinnning på det blir att de får igång folk på lite kickstarter och kommer igång och köra i något program då.
Precis, ja.
Och de säljer ju produkter också.
Ja, och många av de kunderna som kommer in och kör en Ford Boots Challenge blir ju fart på anledningen.
Antingen i form av medlemmar bara och många väljer också att köpa personligt träning för att de tycker att det är en bra sak att få hjälp helt enkelt med att fortsätta sin träningsresa.
Du nämnde att de flesta bolagen ni har haft här har varit inriktade lite på, kan man kalla det runt omkring, tjänster åt gymmen.
Wonder var väl ett bokningssystem och Foodbox är ju mat och kraftmark var ju gymmetrustning.
Så ni täcker runt omkring.
Är det alltid den riktningen ni har gått i att handla mer om gymmen än om att gå direkt mot kund?
Det har det nästan alltid varit.
Vi driver ju ett litet, en liten anläggning i dag.
Jag och Pelle också tillsammans med en kollega som heter Richard Robbins och det är ju Factor Functional Gym i Västerås.
Lite en CrossFit hybrid funktionell träningsanläggning.
Annars var det vårt sista gym vi drev tidigt 2000-tal.
Efter det har vi egentligen fokuserat, jag och Pelle, på att alla de produkter eller koncepten vi har haft har faktiskt varit för att hjälpa våra kollegor att bli mer lönsamma.
Viktningsprogrammen för att de skulle kunna ha ett bredare utbud och Wunder för att de skulle ha ett schysst affärssystem som faktiskt var byggt från, det är ju inte vi som har byggt det men tankarna kom från gymbranschen istället för att det skulle vara ingenjörer som sitter och skapar ett affärssystem.
Vi vill att vi vet vad utmaningarna är, vi vet vad man behöver ha för hjälp på en anläggning och det var ju vår input i Wunder.
Kraftmark, utrustning som kunde hjälpa till att också dra och driva in trafik till anläggningarna.
Vi var ju ganska tidigt ut i det där när CrossFit började komma igång.
Foodbox, självklart en bra serviceprodukt som kan leverera bra, schysst och god mat, nyttig till medlemmarna, utan svin, men samtidigt också vara bidragande till att man faktiskt ökar sina intäkter på sin verksamhet i form av att få nya medlemmar.
Så vi har alltid jobbat åt det håll.
Vi vill ha produkter, vi vill inte bara att de säljer våra produkter, vi vill vara med och hjälpa våra återförsäljare eller kunder eller licensstagare att faktiskt göra bättre business.
Och det är det också med Set the Goal här nu som kommer till hösten, det kanske är vår mest drivande på det sättet koncept som vi har tagit fram hittills.
Vad gäller att få igång verksamheterna därute sen.
Kan du känna en viss irritation över att ni inte har kvar alla koncepten för de, om man får in en på ett koncept kanske man kan sälja nästa koncept.
Jag gissar att det någonstans också kanske var tanken från början.
Så vi har ju kunder och ibland så har våra kunder blivit vänner nästan.
Vi har jobbat så många år med vissa av våra kunder.
Så det är 20-30 år med en del som man har relationen.
Och ibland så tycker man att det där kanske inte är något för mig.
Men många av våra kunder har varit med oss i de flesta av våra koncept och företag.
Tycker du att det är jobbigt att inte ha kontrollen över vart skapelserna tar vägen sedan?
Ja, lite grann.
Lite grann kan jag säga.
Men jag hoppas naturligtvis att allting ska ha hjärtat och få gå åt det hållet man har tänkt.
Men sen vet jag att ibland lämnar man ju stafettpinnen vidare också för att det kanske behövs in lite ny kraft, lite nya vägar och nya möjligheter.
Och ibland känns det väldigt bra att se när ett företag flyger vidare och betyder någonting för andra också.
Så jag är bara glad.
Ja, jag förstår.
Du är så ruttad i detta nu så att du får inte lika hårda känslor längre.
När ni tog fram den här maten första gången, du sa att det var en stor investering, men jag gissar att det också är en relativt stor process att ta fram mat och börja sälja mat och färdig mat och hela det här.
Det är väl mycket regler, gissar jag.
Hur gick den processen till och vad skete sig och vad var lättare än du trodde?
Att ta oss tillbaka lite?
Ja, det var ju där i 2013.
Man satt ner och vi satt några veckor, och försökte tänka till på hur vi skulle göra det här.
Vi började uppfatta fabriker, titta på recept.
Vi var väldigt inriktade på att ska vi nu ha mat så måste det vara bra mat.
Det får inte vara skräpmat.
Det ska vara nyttig mat, utan konserveringsmedel med rätt näringsämnen i kaloriberäknade och alla de här bitarna.
Sedan hade vi den här stora grejen, det är fryset kontra någonting annat.
Sedan gjorde vi våra efterforskningar på hur det här med fryset mat faktiskt funkar.
Det är ju, om man snabbt fryser maten så kommer näringsvärlden att behållas väldigt bra.
Så fryset mat är inte alls fel, utan det är ibland bättre att tida upp en frysrätt och äta än att äta en rätt som kanske har legat i frysen eller i kylen, 2-3 dagar.
Då börjar det redan brytas ner i näringsämnen och så.
Sedan uppvarta lite fabriker, försöka förklara, beskriva vad vi vill göra till att, ja visst det går bra men då är det såhär många rätter och såhär många miljoner som det ska kosta.
Men vi har alltid varit lite våghalsiga entreprenörer så vi sa då, då kör vi på det.
Och så gjorde vi det.
Och sen så bestämde vi oss för att vi skulle börja kontakta våra kollegor i branschen, tränningsanläggningen.
Och sa att nu vill vi komma ut och berätta lite grann om vårt nya här, och det är foodbox, det är frysmat.
Och det har varit ju liksom bara stoppskyltar överallt i början.
Så då var det en liten skraj.
Och vad har vi gjort?
Undrar man ju lite grann.
Men sedan så var man ut, förklarade, utbildat, beskrivit.
Och det har knallt på väldigt bra efter det.
Ni har väl fått in, visst, nu kanske jag har fel, men visst finns ni både på Nordic Wellness och STC.
Är ni på nån mer sån stor kedja?
Ja, Wellness Studio.
Till exempel så Friskers och Svettis har vi en hel del anläggningar som har Foodbox också.
Hur kom ni in där?
Det måste också ha varit en liten process.
Ja, nu har inte jag jobbat själv med det här, utan vi har ju arbetat med Business Coaching också.
Så att vi har väl arbetat hårt och är lite blad, som vi alltid gör med våra saker.
Har vi bestämt oss för någonting, då brukar vi gå för det.
Ni står utanför dörren tills folk godkänner?
Ja, nästan.
Ja, nästan så.
Då sa Sten Hård Sälj.
Angående det här med frys, bara så vi inte tappar det, angående det fryst mat, jag har ju två småungar, en tvååring och en treåring, och givetvis är livet lite halvtajt jämnt, och vi funderar alltid på vad man ska äta för mat.
Men vi köper ju inte fryst mat egentligen.
Och jag tänker att det är en ganska liten del av maten som man köper som är fryst.
Jag har också tränat under många år och tränat mycket, men jag köpte inte fryst mat då, även om mat alltid var ett stort problem.
Vad tror du det är som gör att folk inte köper, varför är inte fryst mat större med tanke på smidigheten i det?
Från början, om man säger 2014 när vi startade med foodbox, så var det nog ännu färre som köpte fryst mat.
Idag tycker jag att det finns mycket fryst mat att köpa.
Sen vet jag att det mesta är inte riktigt av den kvalitén jag skulle vilja köpa.
Det är skit helt enkelt.
Ja, det är mycket.
Det är för mycket konserveringsmedel i.
Det är för dålig näringsinnehåll till antalet kalorier och så vidare.
Men det är inte lika stort motstånd idag.
Jag tror att det säljs ganska mycket fryst mat.
Sen tycker jag också att det kanske borde vara fler som faktiskt var intresserade på gymmen.
Många köper ju och vi säljer väldigt bra.
Men ibland tänker man ju att man kunde få hälften av alla måltider att vara fara.
Foodbox så tror jag att kunderna skulle käka bättre mat.
Foodbox är troligtvis bättre än de flesta måltiderna som man faktiskt äter under en månad.
Där finns maten, det är riktigt bra mat så det är klart man vill sälja mer.
Men jag tror inte att det säljs så lite som det gjorde förr i alla fall.
Utan det är mycket mer vanligt nu idag att man faktiskt har lite schysst käk i fryset.
Vad är det som gör att foodbox, och jag menar inte att foodbox inte är stort, jag bara menar varför det inte är större än vad det är.
Med tanke på, man är på gymmet, ofta ser det väl ut så att man har en foodbox kyl där eller frys där och sen så finns det ofta lite mikrobox under och sånt.
Rent teoretiskt är det ganska smidigt att sätta sig ner och käka och slippa springa iväg.
Hur jobbar ni för att väcka på det här förutom de här kampanjerna som du pratar om?
Det är ju skylt material, såklart.
Utbildar våra återförsäljare, vi ser skillnaden där vi har ju återförsäljare som ligger och snittar 2000 foodboxer i månaden på en anläggning.
Och så har vi andra återförsäljare som har 50 foodboxer i månaden som de säljer.
Och vi säger samma sak till båda våra återförsäljare.
Så det är ju väldigt olika hur man tar det och det är ju det som är den springande punkten.
Gillar man foodboxen själv, jobbar man med den, driver man en träningsanläggning och faktiskt jobbar på ett korrekt sätt med de produkter man har, då säljer man mycket.
Och jag vet ju att människor mår bra av foodbox.
Och de som provar den tycker att det är bra.
Så svaret på den frågan är nog att vi är beroende av alla därute att de jobbar med produkten såklart.
Och vi gör vårt bästa.
Vi jobbar ju hårt för att vi ska ha bra kvalitet på maten, den ska fortsätta vara bra.
Vi byter ut två rätter varje år för att det ska bli lite ombytet.
Vi satsar på vegetariskt också.
De flesta foodboxrätterna köps faktiskt ur frysen och tas med till jobbet eller tas hem.
Så många köper foodboxen och tar med hem.
Och det tycker vi är viktigt också.
Jag tycker vi säljer väldigt bra.
Men det är klart man alltid vill sälja rätt.
Jag fattar, men med tanke på att det är så stor skillnad mellan anläggningar, är ni själva ut och snacka med ägare som ändå är positiva till det men som inte är riktigt pushade eller är det för många anläggningar för att vara ute?
Vi är ut en del.
Vi var ute mer förr.
Vi har...
Vi sitter mycket inne och ringer.
Vi kontaktar våra återförsäljare hela tiden.
Vi ringer hela dagarna.
Vi har sagt att vi vill ringa till våra återförsäljare minst en gång var tredje månad.
Men vi jobbar ju supertajt med vissa.
Och vi jobbar med alla som vill.
Det bästa vi vet är om vi kan kroka arm, kommitta oss till varandra och göra stortod tillsammans.
Det älskar jag.
Så vi jobbar mycket och nära våra kunder hela tiden.
Har det varit mycket konkurrens?
Det var ju liksom en trend där ett tag.
Det kanske fortfarande är en trend.
Jag är inte så inne i kostdelen men det var ett tag när det var mycket sådana här beställ hälsosamma lådor på nätet eller köpfärdiga matgrejer.
Det såg inte ut i er värld men var det liksom en fight omgymmen?
Var det fler koncept som försökte göra det här som ni gjorde?
Det finns hur mycket som helst på nätet att beställa hem och lådor och så vidare.
Men vi har ju varit konsekventa som jag har sagt till dig.
Vi har inte försökt med de sakerna trots att vi kanske har velat butiker, livsmedelsbutiker har vi inte heller gått på utan vi har varit konsekventa.
Jobbat med våra återförsäljare som är framförallt träningsanläggningar.
Jobbat mycket med material runt omkring, med programmen.
Fått om att förstå att vi vill vara med och hjälpa dem att bli mer lönsamma.
Och då vet vi att gör vi det så säljer vi mer foodbox.
Så det är det samarbetet som vi har jobbat med.
Så har vi jobbat med alla våra produkter genom alla år.
Och det kommer nog att fortsätta så.
Jag förstår.
Jag gillar branschen och jag gillar mina kunder.
Jag vill inte förlora dem.
Nej jag fattar.
Men har ni någon riktig konkurrent?
Jag har inte sett så många andra.
Jag har hängt så här jättemycket på gymmen men jag har inte sett någon annan större.
Ingen som kanske har etablerat sig så men det finns ju lokala och de som har lite grann och som har olika rätter in på anläggningarna.
Men många kommer ju in och så försvinner de.
Det är ju svårt att kanske hitta lönsamheten i det här, att sälja.
Det krävs lite volym också kanske.
Mycket volym krävs det.
Ja, det är svårt.
Vi tänker ju oftast bara framåt.
Vi gör det bästa vi kan för våra kunder med de bästa produkterna.
Vi jobbar ganska hårt med just kundkontakten och så våra återförsäljare är ganska säkra och förstår att vi inte bara är utefter att de ska sälja en massa foodbox, utan vi är utefter att de ska göra bra saker med foodboxen, att de ska få in nya medlemmar, att det ska kännas som en bra investering faktiskt, att ha en frys på anläggningen och jobba.
Det är vårt mantra.
Om vi tar själva företaget i sig och dina kollegor och sådär, det måste ändå vara ett företag som är ganska säljfokuserat och ganska, nu ska vi hantera kundens problem, fokuserat liksom.
Vad letar du efter för kollegor när du anställer och hur ser ni till att driva den säljkulturen?
Du är ju många som är lite obekväma i det där.
Ja, dels har vi själva, både jag och min kollega Pelle, jobbat i branschen i hela våra liv.
Vi har drivit många träningsanläggningar själv.
Men vi vet hur man pratar därute.
Träningsbranschen är lite speciell med medlemskap, olika säsonger, utmaningar, vad funkar, vad funkar inte.
Och vi vet också hur svårt det är att ta en som inte är skolad i branschen, en individ, och skola in.
Det tar väldigt lång tid.
Självklart om det är en bra pedagogisk person som är duktig och framåt så har vi gjort det också många gånger.
Men annars letar vi efter duktiga människor i branschen som har varit med ett tag och som har jobbat i branschen ganska länge.
Så det är sådana människor vi främst letar efter.
Jag fattar folk med lite kontakt med.
Ja, det också.
Hur ser framtiden ut här?
Finns Foodbox bara i Sverige eller ska ni utomlands?
Eller är det en tanke eller?
Det är lite roligt att du frågar.
Vi är precis i lag med att ta in Foodbox i Norge.
Okej.
Och sen har vi faktiskt planer på Danmark och Finland också, inom en relativt snar framtid.
Så Norge blir nog i år och Finland och Danmark senast nästa år, nästa första halvår skulle jag tro.
Är det andra regelverk där eller vad är problemen med att gå utanans?
Inte Finland och Danmark.
EU väldigt enkelt.
Där kan vi egentligen bara lasta på Foodboxen på en tradare och åka in.
I Norge är det ju annorlunda.
Norge är betydligt besvärligare.
Men det är ändå ett väldigt nära land.
Norge skulle jag säga är det lättaste landet att jobba med.
Förutom att de ligger utanför EU.
Men startar ni upp ett norskt bolag då eller producerar ni i Norge eller kommer ni fortsätta vara i Sverige?
Vi kommer att fortsätta producera i Sverige.
Och sen exporterar vi det eller importerar det i Norge.
Förmodligen kommer vi att ha ett dotterbolag i Norge.
Det kommer att vara enklast så.
I de här olika företagen som ni har haft och även Foodbox då, är det du och Pelle som är de enda ägarna eller brukar ni ta in folk runt omkring?
Har ni fått in kapital för att gå utomlands nu eller hur ser det?
Nej, det är både och.
Foodbox har det varit jag och Pelle som har varit ägare i.
I Wonder så hade vi flera partner.
Då var jag och Pelle majoritetsaktieägare.
Kraftmark, likaså.
Då hade vi också en kompagnion med, en tredje.
Så då hade jag och Pelle två tredjedelar.
Vår träningsanläggning i Västerås har vi också en delägare till.
Han är också ansvarig för att driva anläggningen.
Så det kan se lite olika ut faktiskt.
Vi har drivit företag, bara gemensamt men också tagit in en tredje partner där vi tycker att kanske jag och Pelle inte har 100-100 kompetenser på allt.
Då arbetar vi gärna med en partner till.
Har ni funderat på att göra det i Foodbox eftersom om man ska gå utomlands, det är väl samma sak där med volym, ni behöver få skickat större volymer och en taktisk...
Ja, inte i vårt svenska bolag, inte i moderbolaget.
Där har vi vårt ägande och Pelle.
Däremot i de utländska bolagen och vi är inte hunnade på hur det kommer att se ut ännu.
Vi tror att vi kommer att vilja ha en partner med oss i varje land som kan vara drivande.
Vi behöver nog det.
Vi kan inte själva vara där och åka och så vidare.
Men då kommer den stora utvecklingen av produkter, både Foodbox som maträtt och även konceptet runt omkring, kommer ju att fortsätta utvecklas i Sverige.
Men sen så kommer vi att kunna föra över det på eventuella samarbetspartner i Norge och Finland.
Vi vill säkert ha någon partner i respektive land med oss.
Och sen om det är direktförsäljning från vårt svenska bolag eller om vi startar upp bolag i de länderna, där är vi inte riktigt säkra på än hur vi ska göra det.
Bara av intresse där, vad är det man letar efter då?
Om man går in i Norge, letar man till exempel efter någon sats person som bara helt plötsligt kan säga att vi sätter in det på alla anläggningar eller ska det vara en fristående mataktör, vad är det man letar efter?
Där har vi en samarbetspartner som vi har jobbat med kring andra koncept också under många år, just i Norge.
I Danmark och i Finland så letar vi just, det vore väl toppen om man kunde hitta någon som satt med.
Vi har redan 100 anläggningar som vi kan etablera oss på.
Vi vill ha drivna människor som vi trivs med.
Vi pratar oftast om det, ska vi jobba med någon?
Pängar är viktigt men inte allt.
Det ska vara roligt, det ska vara någon man trivs med.
Man ska ha samma feeling, känsla.
Det är viktigt för oss.
Det vi vill hitta är drivna personer som gillar att ha skoj och skrattar mycket både i Finland och i Norge.
Och Danmark såklart.
Och Danmark såklart, på efterkälken får de komma.
Om vi kikar lite grann på branschen som helhet, tränningsbranschen eller hälsobranschen, vad man nu vill kalla det.
Hur tror du att det kommer att utvecklas?
Vi kan kolla på Sverige egentligen.
Tror du att vi har några intressanta trender närmaste åren eller där man ska rikta in sig om man vill starta företag i branschen eller om man redan driver någonting?
Ja, jag är ju ofta ut och reser.
I år har jag varit på Örsa, Los Angeles, Fibo-mässan, och på Perforum som är en branschmästare här i Sverige för några veckor sedan.
Och för att inhämta och få en feeling över vad som händer och så.
Och det här med hälsa är det som är det stora.
Det är det heta nu, det är det som kommer och kommer att bli viktigare och viktigare.
Biohacking, trender, må bra, få hela kroppen att må bra.
Att bara träna eller bara tänka på kosten tror jag är, visst det är en start men jag tror på bredden.
Så nischen där, det är att möta upp med hälsperspektivet kommer att vara nyckeln i framtiden.
Men tror du att det kommer bli så att de här 5-10 procenten som faktiskt bryr sig redan jättemycket om kost och träning kommer att lägga till massa extra grejer med sömn och kryo-joks och rödlamp-joks?
Eller tror du att det blir faktiskt ett sätt för nya människor att komma in i branschen?
Risken är ju att det alltid är den här...
Jag tror både och där.
Redan de som är åt det hälsosammanhållet och mår bra och tränar och sköter kosten, just, pratar man ju ofta med sådana människor också men de vill ju också må ännu bättre.
De vet att sover du bra så får du bättre effekt på träningen, och tvärtom.
Men handen på hjärtat, vem mår egentligen sämst?
Den som inte har tränat på sex månader eller den som inte har sovit på sex månader.
Det är ganska enkelt att förstå.
Ja, precis.
Så just det här med att kunna erbjuda människor i större omfång av hälsosamma aktiviteter tror jag mycket på.
Sen kommer det kunna se lite olika ut därute, naturligtvis.
Men nu här när vi var i Los Angeles på Öreshamnässan, det var jag och min kollega Pelle som var där, så bestämde vi oss för att djupdyka litegrann i det här.
Så vi var runt på lite anläggningar, på ett ställe som heter Remedy Place.
Där testade vi kallbad.
Jag var nervös och stressad i tre dagar innan, men jag satt i 5 grader till vatten i sex minuter.
Det gick bra.
Lite IV, alltså du fick vitaminer och mineraler ingesserat i dig för att må bra.
Vi satt i rödljusvastor, i tryckkammare med extra.
Vi gjorde allt man kunde för att se.
Det är sånt som kommer mycket.
Det fanns mycket sånt på utställningen på mässan också, både där och i Tyskland.
Det är mycket det här med hälsan.
Kunskapen har ju utvecklats hela tiden och när man nu kan börja hjälpa människor med både sömn, stress och alla de här sakerna så tror jag att det kommer att bli en öppning.
Både för de som redan är hälsosamma men framförallt som en dörröppnare för de som faktiskt kanske behöver tänka på hälsan men tycker att träning som ord är lite svårt.
Då kan man öppna upp med att vi lärde oss sova bättre.
Kom till oss, till våran träningsanläggning och sluta röka.
Det är klart att det är vi som ska hjälpa dem.
Jag tror att man ska ha ett program eller sluta röka program.
Man måste hjälpa människor.
Det är till oss de ska komma med sånt.
Inte gå till doktorn eller apoteket för att få hjälp.
Men är det verkligen gymmen som ska ta hand om allt sånt här?
För jag tänker att det finns ganska många människor som är lite obekvämma med gym, som inte tränar.
Och då om man vill ha hjälp med sömn så tänker man att jag går in på gymmet så ska de sälja på mig PT och kost.
Jag vill bara ha hjälp med...
Jag har fyra ungar, två med kolleg som bara skriker jag vill ha hjälp med detta.
Hade man inte varit bekvämare och gå till en anläggning som var fokuserad på sömn, avslappning, men som inte är yoga och träning, som bara släpper hela hälsovärlden och så är det...
Det är det också.
Många anläggningar i gym har ju yoga.
Så att det är ett sådant program eller sådant lösning, jo självklart.
Sedan vet vi att träning gör att du sover bättre.
Och att om du sover bättre så fungerar träningen bättre.
Att sitta och inte göra någonting och bara dricka energidrycker, då sover du dåligt.
Att röra på dig mycket, bli fysiskt aktivt slut, ja då sover du bättre.
Så att det hänger lite grann ihop.
Och självklart kanske du inte kan som anläggning ha allt.
Men jag tror att det hänger så mycket ihop.
Alltihopa.
Verktygslåda, din fråga var ju här från början, vad man kunde träna med eller vad nischen skulle vara.
Och om då nischen är hälsa så tror jag att då får man många fler verktyg i sin verktygslåda på en anläggning eller som personligt tränare eller någonting sånt för att verkligen kunna hjälpa sina medlemmar, kunder, klienter.
Jag tycker det ska bli lite intressant för det känns som att det ofta går i sådana cykler.
Man går från specialist till generalist till specialist till generalist.
Sen går utökningen framåt men det ska bli lite kul att se.
Sen tror jag ju som sagt på att det finns en plats för allt.
Men om man tittar på vad som nu är på gång där borta i staten och så vidare sånt så är det mer åt det hälsosamma där.
Vilken mässa ska man åka på om man är i träningsbranschen och känner att här ska jag fokusera i 20 år, vilken är bäst?
Just nu är det Fibo mässa i Tyskland.
Den är nära och den är gigantisk och där har du allt.
I början av min karriär, när jag började bygga träningsanläggningar på 90-talet, så min första resa till en stormässa var 1995.
Då var det Örsa, och då var Örsa störst.
Det var det under ett antal år.
Men idag ska man bara välja en, då är det ju Fibo som gäller.
Ja, den är väldigt smidig att komma till.
Ja, åker man till Örsa i Amerika, då ska man ju passa på att göra som jag och Pelle gör.
Vi bokar in rundvandringar, vi besöker många nya, både träningsställen och hälsoställen och så vidare, så att man får en feeling över vad som trendar.
För där är de fortfarande långt före oss i Europa.
Om man skulle kunna avslutningsvis säga, du har startat upp x antal företag, eller ni har startat upp x antal företag och ändå fått dem att rulla, och även stått av ett gäng, så det har varit lite intressant att se om du kan se några generella grejer som ni har gjort bra för att faktiskt få fäste i den här branschen och faktiskt nå genom bruset med de här olika koncepterna.
Ja, och jag tror att det gäller att hitta sin nisch och verkligen förstå kunderna och behoven som finns under den nischen för att kunna bli framgångsrik.
Jobba hårt och smart.
För framgång kommer inte över en natt eller gratis för den delen heller, utan det är hårt jobb, vara smart och verkligen jobba med både hjärta och hjärna.
Vi brukar ofta säga att först kommer ju en idé med hjärtat och i mavropen att det ska kännas bra.
Sen när vi har det på plats, då verifierar vi allting med Excel-feeler, planering och ekonomi och så vidare.
Det måste kännas bra från början och sen ser man till att det funkar.
Att bygga ett företag med Excel-feeler först och sen på en feeling, den är mycket mycket svårare.
Så inte vi jobbar i alla fall.
Exakt, jag kan tycka att folk alltid säger det här, antingen säger man att man ska vara passionerad eller säger man att man ska vara business, men på något sätt är det ju att man ska vara passionerad nog att orka göra all business som krävs.
Precis, exakt så skulle jag ha sagt.
Men sen handlar det ju mycket om att vara ute och nätverka, bygga relationer i branschen.
Det är jag och Pelle Jäntut, vi är ju på alla de här mässorna.
Det är Amerika, Fibo, det som finns i Sverige är vi på hela tiden.
Man måste lära känna människor i den här branschen.
Vi har också sagt det, vi har varit med länge men vi lär oss fortfarande saker.
Det gäller att alltid vara öppen för att lära nytt och alltid vilja förbättra och utveckla de produkterna, de sakerna du har.
Du måste orka med.
Du kan inte bara ha ett företag och sen låta det vara så.
För att du utvecklas du inte, så utvecklas du.
Det handlar om att vara beredd att göra jobbet hela tiden för att lyckas.
Är du öppen för nya idéer om någon sitter hemma och bara fan jag har en intressant nisch här som man skulle kunna gå in?
Är det dig man ska kontakta då?
Tyvärr är jag för öppen för sådant.
Man vill försöka begränsa sig.
Jag älskar entreprenörer.
Ofta hjälper jag entreprenörer också med råd och tips utan att på något sätt vara med eller engagerade i bolagen.
Jag gillar människor som är entreprenöriga.
Men med årets lopp har man försökt ta ner lite grann.
Nu kom Set a Goal för att det var lite för lite när vi sålde av några grejer.
Man får lite panik men man är alltid välkommen om man har bra idéer eller funderingar till mig.
Då vet ni vart ni ska vända er.
Jag säger ett stort tack för att du var med Frank.
Jätteintressant att höra hela resan.
Det blev mycket mer än bara foodbox.
Tack så mycket själv Joel, det har varit trevligt att vara med.
Jag vill också tacka alla lyssnare som lyssnade på det här.
Och egentligen till hela vår bransch som jag älskar och kommer vara verksam i.
Tills jag inte orkar längre.
Vem mår egentligen sämst?
Den som inte har tränat på sex månader, eller den som inte har sovit på sex månader?
Jag vet inte vad jag hade svarat.